some of America's wealthiest cities face
a growing homeless crisis thousands of
people are living in tents and cars for
months or even longer in Seattle there
are housing shortages and rising rents
due in part to the tech boom an
estimated 5,000 people are living
unsheltered that means homeless but not
sleeping in a shelter for Sunday 60
minutes Anderson Cooper met a family
hoping to avoid another winter
unsheltered in Seattle
in the shadow of Interstate five in
Seattle on a vacant strip a public land
this is ten City three they're about 50
people living here without heat or
running water that's Ethan wood he's
celebrating his third birthday he's
lived in a tent for the past year and a
half
his parents Trisha and Josiah told us
Ethan has an enlarged heart and suffers
from doubts of asthma and croup so
severe they've had to take him to the
emergency room several times last winter
one of Seattle's coldest and recent
memory Ethan was sleeping in a tent
covered with blankets sandwiched between
his parents for warmth did you ever
think well this is not the place we
should have our child we don't want our
son here we don't want to be here but as
of right now this is the safest place
for us absolutely because we know the
people we know the rules and and our
family stays together drug addiction is
what led the woods to become homeless
for Josiah it was meth for Trisha heroin
they were living in Alaska at the time
Josiah's parents took care of Ethan
while they both got treatment Trisha
came to Seattle for rehab and afterwards
decided it was a good city for a fresh
start they say they haven't used drugs
in nearly two years but it's been hard
to find housing in May 2018 they tried
to get a spot in one of Seattle's family
shelters but there was no room they
didn't want to split up into separate
shelters one for men and another for
women with children so they found their
way to tent city three and decided to
stay
well this is America I mean this is a
problem that's affecting a lot of people
and I think putting a face on it in that
way
definitely you know concerned about you
know what do we need to do to help that
that crisis in this country breaks my
heart to see that little boy - yeah you
know you see the parents but you think
about that little baby
yeah he's young enough though that it's
in a it could be possibly an adventure
but the fact that he has a health crisis
that they're managing in the midst of it
as winter approaches you would think
that there's someone who could offer
helped exactly well you can see more of
Anderson Cooper's report on 60 minutes
he talks with Seattle's mayor about what
the city is doing to ease this crisis
and why it's happening in the first
place that's Sunday night on 60 minutes